schools across most of pakistan are said
to make the teaching of the holy quran
compulsory from later this year students
will be expected to read the entire
quran with translation
learn islamic prayers and memorize a
number of sayings of the prophet
muhammad
the move comes just months after the
country's senate made
arabic language teaching mandatory in
schools in the capital islamabad
critics accuse the government of cow
towing to islamic parties with these
plans
studying already keeps zenith and her
friends busy the whole day
but very soon their islamabad school
will add another subject
arabic zenith wants to study art in the
future
she's not interested in a new required
language at all
already in a covet situation it's really
hard for
us to study and go with
our subjects and adding arabic as a
compulsory subject
it's really hard the government argues
that the new curriculum
will help students understand the quran
better and provide
future job opportunities in the middle
east
but many students in the capital region
already have to learn two languages
urdu and english they say adding a third
and a pandemic
is just too much educational reformers
are also
raising concerns the actual reason that
we see is that
during this government there has been a
trend
towards islamization of education
and in august another government mandate
goes into effect
making islamic education compulsory in
nearly all schools
it's part of a new single national
curriculum
a move liberal reformers also warn will
increase the influence of religious
clerics
and fuel intolerance these ones are
passed in one single day
this is the power that now the clergy
actually um feels that it has
that it can take up this name and the
the this will be passed so for example
all the blasphemy laws in pakistan were
passed
just like that a human rights group has
challenged the curriculum changes in the
nation's highest court
over concern for religious minorities
come august pakistani youth no matter
their beliefs
could potentially have no choice in the
matter
joining me for more now is parvez hudbai
he's a nuclear physicist and a noted
educationist
he joins me from the pakistani capital
islamabad welcome mr hoothby
how fair is the claim that these recent
moves by the government
point to an islamization of education in
the country
well it's not just islamization it's
islamization
at a frantic pace it's uh
far speedier now than it was in the days
of general xiaoloch
who started this trend towards infusing
religion into every level of education
so that now is faster than ever before
and it's
at several different levels at the
school level the
primary level the middle high school
and then it goes all the way up to
university
at the university level you cannot get a
degree
whether that be a bachelor's a masters
or a phd
without studying the quran and without
taking an
exam on the quran and that was a
unanimous
decision of the punjab assembly last
july
that is in 2020 at the school level
the changes are absolutely frightening
for someone who believes that children
should be able to think for themselves
here they're being propagandized
at a pace never seen before right so
what you're saying is that the
government of uh prime minister imran
khan
is trying to appease islamic parties
with these moves i
suppose that is a major reason but it is
also that imran khan is a fundamentalist
there is absolutely no doubt about that
he says he's proud to be a
fundamentalist
says that he wants to make pakistan
the state of madina riyasati madina
and he said this in his opening speech
he's repeated it about a dozen times so
far
and he says that he wants regular
schools
and madrasas to have the same curriculum
he says there should not be a difference
between them
and so well you are right that he wants
to appease the
extreme right but he's also pretty right
himself
i mean it's quite a thing to say uh mr
hudba if you don't mind me
pointing this out that the prime
minister of pakistan is
a fundamentalist but then to go back to
the point about
the teaching of the holy quran in
schools pakistan is at the end of the
day an islamic republic what is wrong
with the holy quran being taught in its
schools
oh if it's taught at home there's no
problem but if
if if you in if you make
the education in public schools and
private schools
that of the madrasas then you don't have
a
hope of being with the modern world if
children are expected to
and and this is i'm being very factual
about
it their children are being expected to
remember
not just the quran in arabic
but the translation in urdu
they've been required to learn hades's
in arabic
with urdu translations and apart from it
all
a certain number of prayers like what
prayer to save
while climbing up a flight of stairs
what to say when you walk down
what should you say at the beginning of
a meal
what if you burp this it's
become absurd the amount of
religion that is being thrust into our
children
is incredible and what is this going to
lead to
a nation which is which is
anchored in the 7th century
so what you're also saying is that the
government of pakistan
is ruining the future of pakistan
through its children
this is what i have been saying and my
colleagues have been saying now for the
three years that this government has
been in power
and this govern government is adamant it
says that
only by making the education of the
madrasas
which are islamic seminaries the same
as that of the regular schools in fact
removing distance
differences between them and this is
what is called the single
national curriculum only in this way
can we hope to get to an islamic
republic with all the
good things about it and so forth there
is
no this sort of education
is uh simply going to take us back into
the dark ages
we'll have to leave it there for the
time being but thank you so much for
joining us sir
you